well the fires raging in northern
california have now become some of the
largest
in state history more than 12 000
firefighters are currently
battling the blazes that have killed six
people governor governor newsom said
help is arriving from several u.s states
he also put in a plea for assistance
from australia
and canada well the fires were started
by lightning strikes and have forced
tens of thousands to flee to safety
this is all that's left of karen
hansen's home
in northern california she and her
family only had two minutes to evacuate
their small
farm before flames obliterated it
i've never seen anything like it it was
the whole sky was red and orange
i mean that's it i don't know it was
just red and orange
and it was coming over the hill there
and it was massive i've never seen
anything like it
and it only took a few minutes to get
here the flames she describes are still
making their way across california in
the form of hundreds of separate fires
they were sparked by thousands of
lightning strikes and
fanned by record-breaking heat with more
than three thousand square kilometers of
land destroyed
many fear their plot may be next
i'm really worried because if it burns
down
the next few days i don't have a place
to live
by tomorrow maybe you know i'll know
more but pretty much i'm
i'm thinking we're going to lose the
house for now it's unpredictable nature
versus an understaffed firefighting
force
authorities have warned that much of
what will happen next depends on weather
conditions
as the heat wave continues across
california
many more properties are likely to
succumb to the flames
you